-Mr. Russell believes
that you made a mistake.
-You have never met my wife.
-She helped me one night.
We spent the evening together.
-No, no. No, I don't think so.
-In fact, he came here
looking for her.
-I-I was looking for my...son.
Not my wife. And you told me
no one had been here.
-I lied.
We played gin.
-Why would you lie about that?
-I was afraid that you would
punish her.
-For playing gin?
-It doesn't matter.
The point is, Dr. Fox,
is that nothing's happened
-No.
-Hm?
-No. I know what I saw.
-Nothing's happened to anyone.
-No, I-I was zoomed in
with -- with the camera.
-Did you take a picture?
-No, I did not take a picture.
-She's just admitted
she's spying on our house.
-Why didn't you take a picture
-Mr. Russell, please, just -
The important thing is,
is that everybody's okay.
-That was a clip from, eh,
the new "Enchanted" film.
[ Laughter ]
Welcome back to "Late Night.
We're here with Amy Adams.
So, this is a fantastic
noirish thriller.
You play an agoraphobic woman.
And it should be noted, yo
filmed this three years ago --
very ahead of the times
insofar as you're playing
a character
who is trapped inside.
-Trapped inside of her house
Yes.
So, I...
It was a very different time
But it was -- it was an amazin
experience to film it
'cause we really were inside
of a studio in Brooklyn,
and it was perpetual darknes
for weeks on end.
-You play a character who feel
as though you witnessed a murder
and nobody trusts you.
And it's very nice
when a clip comes with a fil
and you get a sense of exactly
how good the cast is,
and that is certainly true
in this film.
-Aw, thanks.
It was an amazing cast.
We have so many talented actor
in it, and I was just floore
that they all showed up
to support this film.
It was a real honor
to work with them all.
-You play a character who ha
some alcohol addiction issues.
I'm wondering...I feel lik
you're getting pretty good
at, um...
acting drunk.
-[ Laughs ]
-And I just want to tip my cap
Do you have any tips?
I mean, what have you learne
that makes it so believable?
-I'm just gonna
plead the fifth here.
No, I mean, what's interesting
is, I was a little nervous
playing people who were
struggling with substance abuse,
but they all had a different -
You have to understand
the reason behind,
because it's very different,
you know.
-Sure.
-In Anna's case, it's a form o
self-medicating from trauma.
So, she's trying to escape
a trauma that she experienced.
Yes.
-There's also a great deal
of stair acting in this film
-Yes.
-It takes place in an apartment.
It is a thriller.
There's a lot of running
up and down stairs.
Did you know
what you were getting into
when you took this role?
-I did not.
I did not know that
it was going to be so aerobic.
-Yeah. [ Laughs ]
-Yeah.
I think, one take, Joe had m
run up and down the stairs
about 25 times.
He wanted it to feel --
He wanted to really get
the sense of the anxiety,
and he got it.
[ Both laugh ]
Yeah.
-Your character also does some
peeping in on their neighbors.
I know, a lot of actors,
a lot of great actors,
one of the reasons
they're particularly good
at playing different peopl
is they observe
the human condition.
Are you someone that feels lik
you are a good people watcher?
-You mean, am -- am I a voyeur
-Yeah, I mean,
voyeur is certainly
the fancy way of saying it
"People watching? Never!
I like to voyeur."
-Okay.
Well, no, no. I feel like
one implies a bit of...
Like, for example, my husban
will always get --
Even if we're on a hike
and we get, like, around
where you can hear
someone's conversation,
I'll slow down
and get really quiet.
And it's fascinating what yo
can pick up from people.
Yeah.
-Now, this is interesting.
I want to ask,
has, like, a mask --
'cause I'm assuming, you're on
a hike, you're wearing a mask.
Is that helpful,
being Amy Adams,
insofar as you can eavesdrop
a little bit better
without the fear
of being recognized?
-I would eavesdrop even if
people did recognize me.
[ Both laugh ]
I will eavesdrop
anywhere, anytime.
If you're next to me at a
restaurant, I will --
if we get to go
to restaurants again,
I will -- I will listen to you
-You're gonna just
sit right down and say,
"Hello, I'm Amy Adams
and I will be listening in."
-It's not that graceful.
It's usually something like this
and it's not very subtle.
It's like...
-[ Laughing ]
Yeah, but definitely, I have t
say, recognizably you.
Very -- There's no one
that could've been but you
Hey, can you tell me --
I hope I'm getting this right --
is it the RightWay?
-Yes, Yes.
The RightWay Foundation.
May is Foster Care Month,
and I'm working with
an organization
called the RightWay Foundation
that is based
out of Los Angeles.
And they help transition-age
foster youth
kind of move out of the system
and into a successful life
-That's wonderful.
Thank you so much
for doing that.
And thank you so much
for being here
and joining us from overseas
I cannot wait to see
"Disenchanted,"
and the film is wonderful.
-Thank you so much.
It's good to see you.
I hope your family
is safe and well.
-Same to you, and hopefull
next time in person.
"The Woman in the Window" begins
streaming on Netflix May 14th.